in 1967 the paac sky bus
also known as the transit expressway
revenue line was set to revolutionize
pittsburgh's public transit
it was slick shiny futuristic completely
automated promising a quick and
comfortable ride on tracks elevated
above traffic
the system ran these small automated
buses because back then you were allowed
to call the buses instead of pods
each bus had 28 seats a max speed of 80
kilometers per hour and electric motors
powered by a third rail
now you might say um adam so far this
sounds
suspiciously like a train a very low
capacity and needlessly over
engineered train and that's because it
is more on that in a bit
this kind bus was envisioned as this
sort of gap filler between buses and
subways because trams don't exist
apparently
but in the end it failed to amount to
anything while the port authority of
allegheny county pac supported the
introduction of the sky bus
both the mayor and the governor opposed
it favoring instead a mixture of heavy
and light rail
the demonstrator line opened up in 1967
and turned out to be quite popular
it was quite the novelty for its time
you know a fully automated transit
system for 1967
it's a big deal but after almost a
decade of political battles
funding and support for the skype was
finally evaporated and by 1980 the
demonstrator line was dismantled
completely despite that however the
developer westinghouse went on to build
the miami metro mover afterwards which
is actually operational to this day
and so systems like the sky bus the
miami metro mover and also monorails in
general
are what we call gadget barn now gadget
bones have essentially the same
operational characteristics as regular
trains
they're metal boxes running between
stations on continuous tracks that need
gentle curves and small elevations but
every gadget bond seems to have some
needless twist
that sets it apart from regular trains
mostly for the sake of not being a train
because turns out the techno [ __ ]
factor is very good at attracting public
support and funding
let's say the city center needs to be
connected with a suburb or something
if the city proposes a light rail line
they might get a fair amount of support
with a third of the population screaming
communism
at least in the u.s but if elon musk
comes along and instead proposes the
epic bacon 420 pickle rick pot shuttle
which would be like a normal lighter
line but with half the capacity or
something
he would get positive uncritical global
media coverage for a month
now that being said the sky bus and
gadget bonds in general have the exact
same operational constraints as regular
trains
which means they must also deal with the
exact same problems
speed energy cost comfort capacity
accessibility and safety and if you can
come up with a system that does well in
all these categories
then congratulations you've
revolutionized transportation
unironically
in real life though overcoming one
problem usually results in exacerbating
others
want to have high speeds going above 300
kilometers per hour will skyrocket your
energy use
in all cases you will also need very
straight tracks with minimal curves
which will drive up costs due to land
purchases
do you want to have low energy use
you'll have to decrease speeds or
capacity or build out costly energy
infrastructure like solar farms next to
the tracks or something
want to have low construction costs
you'll have to use existing right away
such as roads which are usually designed
for lower speeds
you will also need to build on ground
level and have ad create crossings
further decreasing speed and safety
and so on and so forth now that being
said most of the problems
can be solved by almost any gadget bond
but at the expense of horrendously
exacerbating another
and so even if your futuristic techno
system does really well
in 6 out of 7 aspects failing on the 7th
is usually enough for your competition
to demolish you
and that's because your competition is
conventional rail
from trims to high speed rail turns out
trains can solve all seven problems
reasonably well
meaning they'll perform exceptionally
well in some aspects while not running
into the red in any others
these kibas would have been somewhat
fast not that energy efficient but
comfortable
safe maybe accessible but very expensive
11 miles of sky bus plus 18 miles of
conventional bus right away costing
twice as much as 28 miles of light rail
it was also laughably bad in terms of
capacity seriously now for perspective
three of these things hooked up together
would seat as many people as
one hungarian suburban passenger car
from the 60s
70s oh wow look we doubled the skybox's
capacity what kind of tactical miracle
is this
contrasts the sky bus with something
proven tried and tested like
conventional light rail
it's reasonably fast energy efficient
comfortable safe
accessible not too expensive and good at
scaling out capacity
any sane public official will take one
look at this and go yep we're doing the
light rail even if the sky bus promises
to improve its characteristics on the
way
because it's just that a promise with no
guarantee for example concerns about the
sky buses switching system remained
unresolved all the way to the end
and the thing is if projects like the
skybus were truly viable
they would bring a complete system to
the competition with all the issues
already worked out completely
because if the idea was viable they
would have no trouble attracting private
funding for research and development
hell even complete [ __ ] like
theranos and juicero could attract
horrendous amounts of investment
a further problem with systems like the
sky bus and gadget bonds in general
is interoperability so over here in city
skylines we have this international
airport which we would like to connect
to this
commercial district with convention
centers stadiums etc and then go further
on to the city center to this train
station
so first off we can do it by building a
gadget bond in this case it's a monorail
so as you can see here the connection is
up and running and it is possible to get
from the airport to the commercial
district and then to the train station
all three are neatly linked up by the
monorail alright so let's now try doing
the same thing with conventional rail
and see what happens
now the thing about conventional rail is
that while the monorail was this sort of
island service existing completely
separately from all other transit
conventional rail can be neatly
integrated into the existing system
and this is actually pretty good because
now we can have all kinds of trains
stopped by the airport you know if you
have some suburban trains or long
distance trains coming in from the west
they can just stop by the airport and
offload the passengers who want to fly
instead of you know having to travel all
the way to the central station and then
there change to a monorail which then
will take them to the airport
and if you want to go from the airport
to the commercial district then you can
take some rapid bus service or something
when it's not that far away
but beyond issues like feasibility and
interoperability
gadget bonds have one less fatal flaw
it's that
they are built to solve the wrong
problem so let's ask ourselves the
question
why do we want to build things like the
sky bus the loop the miami metro mover
monorails and other gadget bonds well so
that we can travel quickly above the
congested streets
but why are the streets congested well
because we gave them over to cars
so instead of trying to come up with
elaborate over-engineered solutions to
traffic issues
why not start addressing the real
problem why not try to cut back on car
use it worked in london
paris barcelona stockholm vienna and it
will work in the us
even in west coast cities let's take
away a few lanes from cars and turn them
into dedicated lanes for public transit
suddenly we no longer need to build
elaborate elevated track systems
we can just put some tracks in the
middle or some bus lanes on the sides
and the best part is taking away lanes
from cars inhibitor public transit will
decrease congestion because induced
demand works the other way around as
well
building a sky bus or monorail or any
other techno miracle system to fix urban
mobility is like taking painkillers
against a brain tumor
it might help with some of the symptoms
but the tumor will keep taking more and
more space inside your skull
until you die that's my metaphor for a
city becoming unlivable
and this is why the sky bus and other
gadget bounce systems are basically
pointless they are shiny futuristic
half-paid solutions to the wrong problem
if we really want to quote unquote fixed
traffic we need to
a cut back car use drastically so and b
build a [ __ ] train which pittsburgh
actually did in the end so good for them
every other solution is just a band-aid
on a bullet wound basically
a shiny band-aid with the occasional
gamer lights
thank you for watching please like and
subscribe if you haven't already and i
would also like to thank my patrons for
helping me run this channel
and if you also want to support me
through patreon the link is down in the
description
thank you for watching and see you next
time
you